[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsay show where dad
is dumb cash is king and the paid off
home mortgage has taken the place of the
bmw as the status symbol of choice
number one best-selling author yeah
ramsey personality dr john deloney joins
me this hour this day as my co-host
we're going to help people build wealth
do work that they love and create
absolutely amazing and real
relationships so this is the first time
you've been back on the air with me
anyway uh since you officially
made
own your past change your future a
number one bestseller pretty cool huh
it's very cool very proud of you thank
you man i appreciate all your help
getting the thing out there
very well done and what that means is
the not so complicated approach to
relationships mental health and wellness
is helping a lot
tens of thousands of people in the first
week that it came out and uh the sales
have been
astronomical thank you guys out there
all of you you're the ones actually that
made it a number one uh but uh the fact
that
that you dr john had something to say
that people need to hear
uh this idea own your past and change
your future and
you know i kind of think
that the subject matters caught caught a
wave of
i'm hearing a lot of other stuff said
the same the same stuff said different
ways coming from a lot of people right
now yeah i think there's about 15 or 20
years of research and practice and
people just so frustrated and there's
been some constriction on
you know by by these
national groups like we don't say this
and we don't say that and i think people
are starting to peel off and say
enough's enough we gotta do something
different yeah
well in terms of the uh psychological
jargon and the nursery the nerd world
but i'm more saying that you know coming
out of covid coming out of
uh you know and coming headlong into
inflation headlong into interest rates
raising gas prices are ridiculous
political political climate's completely
unstable
uh in the middle of all that a lot of
people are going now wait a minute yeah
you know all this stuff i've been
feeling uh all these um
i mean the gears are the oils out of the
engine the water whatever the water's
out of the tank whatever whatever phrase
you want to use and i'm i'm down to
nothing i'm empty
and uh so owning your past owning what
we've all just been through is part of
walking out of this not just through it
that's right and then deciding like
what am i going to do next yeah and i've
and i think i'm hoping that we're
reaching a tipping point or have already
fallen over the edge of
i've got to stop going to this
electronic box or this media system or
this entertainment system to try to fill
in those gaps to try to
numb myself through these days i need to
go back to doing things like moving my
body and being around people that i love
and laughing and going bowling again for
god's sake doing some things together
right if you're living on the news
channels you are perpetually afraid or
perpetually angry or both you're
choosing misery that's i mean it's a cho
i'm choosing to be more miserable the
same thing is true when i you know the
only relationships i have are a
smartphone in my hand and those aren't
real relationships right
and so people i think people are waking
up to that i think there's i think
there's a relationship revolution
facebook stock is down yeah you know
it's people are waking up going those
aren't real friends yeah or they were at
one time and we shared some funny
memories but i've got to live in my
neighborhood today right now yeah it
turns out the guy i knew in high school
i like him he's fine but he's not my
best friend anymore don't really care
that's right i don't and hey uh we we
threw the gauntlet down for dallas
y'all showed up man yeah they did and
here's the thing both in phoenix and in
dallas we got together for book signings
and talking
i i was at places as varied as i spoke
at the university of north texas health
science center to their medical to the
faculty and administrators and students
of the medical school and then i spoke
to u-haul and i spoke to a group of
people who run a coffee company dutch
pro everybody in between
everybody's wrestling with the same
stuff
and it's it's time for collectively to
say you know what i'm putting all the
notes i'm turning the off buttons off
and we're going to get together yep
we're just going to get together the the
energy in the room was not
far exceeded how good this book is let
me say that there was people ready to
get back together whether they're gonna
they're gonna burn it down whether it's
a mosh pit or it's a barnes and noble
they're getting together and i'm just
excited to be out here in this moment
it's the truth that's the truth the book
is own your past change your future the
phone number here triple eight eight two
five five two two five brittany starts
this hour in canada hi brittany how are
you
hello dave hello dr john i'm feeling
great today how are you better than we
deserve what's up
i'm glad to hear it well i just found
out last night that i got into law
school wow so
yeah i'm very excited i've worked so
hard for this and you know put myself
through um
university while being a single mother
and i'm working full time to save up to
cash flow law school
um however prior to learning of my
acceptance just last night i was
throwing around the idea of taking the
mortgage broker training which only cost
500
versus the law school tuition at 20k per
year
and i'm starting to now that i'm i'm
excited but i'm feeling a little bit
nervous because it is such a huge
financial commitment and i just kind of
wanted to walk through that with you and
get some insight
i have worked with
i mean i was the dean of students at a
law school so i've got a insider view of
that
i don't know a lot about mortgage
brokers i can let dave speak to that
what i would tell you is if you have the
opportunity to cash flow law school and
be a licensed attorney and that's
something that you have passion and
interest in whether it's you want to
help people navigate complex contract
issues you want to help innocent people
get out of jail
you want to be like protect whatever the
reason is
man there is there's few investments
more powerful there's few positions more
powerful than having a um being a
licensed attorney you can help people in
ways that many guys like me can't
the other side of that is people go to
law school because they want prestige
they want to be rich and the data is
showing us that that's not the case for
the vast majority of attorneys that are
getting out and they're getting out with
a ton of debt and they're making 65 to
85 000 bucks a year here in the us
and it's just a slog it's a hard hard
job and so i think you have to ask
yourself why would i want to do that um
if you had the money and you said i
really want to be attorney i would high
five you all the way dave i don't know
about mortgage brokers as an outsider
the last industry i want to get into
when i'm looking down the barrel the
next 24 36 months is is dealing with
with uh
you know finance of you know any kind of
trading or any of that kind of stuff
but i may be off there yeah i talked to
a guy yesterday in phoenix that uh the
mortgage broker he worked for
laid off 100 of them thursday
because with interest rates ticking up
the
refi's have slowed way down
and a lot of their business was based on
refi
more so than purchases and purchases
slowed down because there's no inventory
so um
regardless of that mortgage brokering is
a valid
uh long-term
career plan now maybe it might be a hard
six months or something coming up but
it's a valid long-term career plan if
that's what you want to do but that
isn't what i'm concerned about just in
the way you told the story
i've always dreamed of i was so excited
when i finally
everything was perfect
when i got lost school
oh wait a minute there's there's a
mortgage broker squirrel
squirrel
and i you kind of sound like a dog
chasing a car and you caught it and
didn't know what to do
yeah
i think i think it's i think it scared
you a little bit that now you've got to
live this dream that you've been working
hard a little bit and i think you throw
your shoulders back have some courage
and go be a lawyer
yeah that's just that's just papa dave
talking that's not necessarily career
advice i was just listening to the way
you talked it through
that's all
this is the ramsay shaft
[Applause]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
number one best-selling author and
ramsey personality dr john dolone is my
co-host today well it's event week you
guys hey las vegas i hope you're ready
because we're gonna be seeing you guys
for a building wealth
live event in just two days we will be
there this thursday evening dr john
dallony ken coleman
rachel cruz george camel and hi if you
haven't reserved your seats yet what are
you waiting for come see us it's going
to be an action-packed night we're going
to walk you through the crazy stuff
going on out there in the world of money
teach you how to build real wealth and
we're going to have a good discussion
with all the ramsey personalities about
what's going on out here in the society
in general this culture is something
that we all have to learn to walk around
in right now without losing our
principles and also not losing our
freaking minds in the process
so again rachel cruz george campbell dr
john daloni ken coleman hosting a free
bonus session about work and
relationships before the event you don't
want to miss that vegas there are some
seats left we'll still we still can see
you on thursday orlando same situation
orlando's very close to being sold out
it's in two weeks
and we're coming to see you very very
quickly and then in the fall we have
launched uh the building wealth series
in sacramento minneapolis and san
antonio in november
110 and 15 respectively tickets are 25
for any of these building wealth events
a four pack is 60
so uh get a couple of your friends
comments less than the cost of a pizza
so gonna be a lot of fun you'll learn
stuff you'll come away inspired informed
you'll have new information you didn't
have before and uh you you'll go home
thinking you know what i can do this
ramsay solutions dot com slash events to
get your tickets right now our question
of the day comes from blinds.com find
out for yourself why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings free samples free
shipping with the new promos they run
all the time you save even more the
promo code is ramsey
today's question comes from marissa in
new mexico marissa writes i introduced
the baby steps to my ex-boyfriend we
were in an emotionally unhealthy
relationship but decided to live
together we opened a joint emergency
fund account and a joint checking
account to pay our bills and we both
brought 10 000 to the emergency fund he
had no debt but i owed 4 800 bucks when
we opened the checking account so we
paid that off we broke up last week and
now he wants the money back he's calling
me a thief a scammer and is threatening
to post on social that i used all his
money
i'm afraid he will make me lose my job
or go to my daughter's school to post
signs saying that i'm a thief
i want to do the right thing but it
seems like since we paid the debt and
we've decided to join our incomes i do
not owe him anything even if we broke up
two weeks after what is your advice
so
sometimes dave people get tied up in
these relationships and it gets real
close and you're someone's telling me a
story and i'll stop them
and say hey
that's harassment or that's abuse and
you watch the light bulb go on and they
go oh i did
oh
right
and so i think there's something to be
said we're gonna have the conversation
about money but if you are afraid that
somebody is going to make you lose your
job if you're afraid that someone's
going to go to your kid's school and
harass them embarrass you
then you need to call the authorities
and get people involved in this
conversation because this is bigger than
you this is different than just a bad
breakup this is somebody who's you're
afraid is going to actively try to seek
to destroy your life
so there's my little discussion on that
dave all right so help me with this
question dave what do you think
well i i
um
i i grew up in a neighborhood where the
first thing we learned was what you do
with a bully as you hit them in the nose
you don't
give them more power right you take
their power away immediately
and so that's my redneck reaction
it's your new book that's my neck
reaction
reaction that's it just pop them in the
nose and then and then they can stop and
think about their mouth okay
um but the of course we're not literally
physically recommending that these days
but um
yeah that that happened in a different
generation and um
but it sets it does set the dna of
something like this so consequently i
still to this day i i
don't uh do a good job i don't always
use good wisdom when i'm dealing with a
bully
because my first reaction is just game
on you know uh and that's not always the
best reaction yeah so that's what we're
dealing with here this guy's a bully
that's right
and
um so i i don't want you to pay the 4
800 even if i thought you owed it right
now because your reason for doing it is
fear and that is not the right reason to
do it if you want to pay the 4 800 your
reason for doing it needs to be on
principle that you feel like yeah i owe
him that money i owe him that money
because the way this deal went down it's
not right and i should do it right
and i kind of think that's true yeah i
kind of think you do owe him the money
but uh but i don't want you to do it
until your heart rate changes and drops
down because right now your heart's
beating a thousand miles a minute
because you're scared of somebody yeah
right and and that's
and he thinks and i actually don't want
him to think he got the money because of
that either because he bowed up on yeah
and it's like
he's gonna he's gonna threaten you and
because then what's he gonna threaten
you for next time that's right you know
and so
but um and and
so
and the other part of this is the the
the
and you can speak to this better than i
can but that
uh
we were in an emotionally unhealthy
relationship but we moved in together
anyway which you know what that tells me
it tells me you're going to go back yeah
or you're going to find another
emotionally unhealthy you're going to go
back you're going to go back to this guy
if you're not careful and so what i want
for you is for him to never
see you speak to you or have any voices
in your head ever again correct when
this is done right uh and the next time
you see an unhealthy relationship i want
you to go no wait i'm a princess
i'm valuable
and i'm i'm so valuable that i don't
need to be entering into an unhealthy
relationship translation i don't need to
sleep with a bully all right and so
here's a couple things you can do you
can go to your boss ahead of time and
say hey
here's a good example this actually
happened dave a year ago um something
back from my past came up and i call i i
emailed you right away and said hey just
so you know everything's clear here this
came up and i i preemptively got ahead
of this thing right i came and told you
it ended up being nothing nothing being
a thing but i'd go to my boss and say
hey
i've got an out of control somebody
ex-boyfriend
i don't know if he's going to see you or
not but just in case he did just know
you just need to know this guy's a bozo
and he'll come in looking like a clown
and you'll know he's a clown that's
right
same with the school hey if this guy
comes around call 911 get him off your
property get the security guys out here
and remove him and uh so forth and just
just be on on guard and i've already
also i've already let the authorities
know and i'm filing for a restraining
order that's right um now once you've
done all that then then don't go back
and don't find another one to replace
him okay
so you know what do you any time i do
something stupid i try to figure out
what it was
so i don't do it again
if i'm gonna do stupid stuff it needs to
be new stupid stuff
okay that's your next book new stupid
stuff by dave ramsey we got a lot of
books coming out today okay number one
bestsellers everywhere redneck reaction
and yeah
new stupid stuff but it's stupid but the
uh uh but you know the thing is that
i i think there's a tremendous
statistical probability that she cycles
back if she doesn't break the mold on
this that's right and and it feels like
uh marissa you're trying to soft land
this thing yeah and you want to that's
fair keep this guy in the relationship
you want to figure out how to keep your
money but not have to do it's all about
you're terrified
i want you to stone cold this guy yeah
and give him the money back block him on
everything okay so let's get into that
they got together well they shouldn't
have done any of this yeah i read um i
introduced them to your baby steps i
want to say no you didn't you like a
weird part of the baby steps well you
made you up your own plan where we can
live together in an unhealthy
relationship and then combine our money
when we're not married that we have
never told anybody anything except never
do that because of this because of this
right
this is what happens when you shack up
with people you aren't married to and
you play house
because you want to wear the shoes for a
week before you actually buy them so
i've got no debt i owe 400 bucks they
paid it he he paid it off
technically i think they both they 10k
in there so there's 20 grand in there
and then they paid off 4 800 out of that
sounds like maybe she splits it he needs
to get his 10 grand back total
and it's probably down by something
yeah and then but kiddo
love yourself enough
put the stiff arm on the bozo
permanently block him on everything and
anybody that even smells like him ever
again
oh wait a minute wait a minute that i
smell bozo no
walk away
[Music]
i say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important you've got to know where you
stand so you make your next move the
right move
and you don't have to be in the dark
here over 31 000 businesses including my
team at ramsey know their numbers
because they use netsuite by oracle the
number one cloud financial system
netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improved margins having everything in
one place has saved my team hours each
week since we made the switch to
netsuite netsuite is a game changer so
head on over to netsuite.com ramsey to
get a product tour today that's
netsuite.com
ramsey
[Music]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt-free stage mike
and cat are with us hey guys how are you
good how are you good welcome where do
you guys live
cape cod it's complicated at the moment
okay cape cod i'm going with it run with
it i love it i love it well i got to
visit there back in the fall for the
first time in my life and i absolutely
loved it beautiful area it is absolutely
a lot of fun well welcome to nashville
and you're here to do a debt-free stream
how much have you paid off
206 000. whoa how long did this take 31
months
to had gum and your range of income
during that time
we went from uh 67 000 to 256 000 in two
and a half years yes sir that's a story
in and of itself what do you guys do for
a living and what in the world happened
to your income
um i went from delivering beer
to driving entertainment
personnel put it that way okay all right
and i went from trying to run a small
business just out of college doing about
17 000 a year to realizing i was
terrible at it and throwing the baby out
with the bathwater and going back to the
drawing board and i'm now a project
manager oh very good very very good okay
wow so both of you maximized your
careers during this period of time
obviously changed directions when a lot
of different stuff so it sounds like you
do a little bit of personal security as
well mike yes okay all right perfect
good for you what kind of debt was the
206 000 who everything everything you
name it we had credit cards we had legal
fees we had irs debt we had we had a ch
oh a lot between the two of us
um that was i would say literally
everything
y'all were kind of normal
yeah normal like a mess yeah like a hot
mess i didn't even realize it
how long you been married
oh a little while now we uh we haven't
had the ceremony yet during all this
process so
to me not not yet because i want that
big party eventually okay all right look
at the paper get the paper and the kids
we're working on the uh celebrating part
okay all right so we have to circle back
on that yeah okay all right the uh what
got all this started 31 months ago where
you say uh this ramsay stuff this
hillbilly down south we gotta check this
out i'm gonna blame it on her
good good yeah like blaming it on her
we did about 10 months of fish prior i
had a book from my ex-fiance's father
called total money makeover hanging out
on my shelf and i had tried to
get a mortgage doing all the paperwork
and realized we were not going to do
well
and i finally sat down and read said
book and in the book was a thousand
dollars for baby step one as i finally
read what had been on my shelf for five
years
so that was the beginning of the end and
realizing like i needed to get him on
board and
what we could do to get there and that
we needed a bigger shovel mike she walks
in with all these ideas what'd you say
um they looked and was like this is
impossible
absolutely not and then i
kind of
i cash flowed a lawyer and was like oh i
can actually do this it's the first time
i've ever cash flowed a lawyer i've
always had to pay for pay for it out of
uh get a loan from my mother or get a
loan from somebody else like a friend
and uh that was pretty much when i cash
flowed i was like i can actually do this
oh oh my god i can do this all right so
then it started going let's do this
let's do this and
having her pretty much be the nerd of
the whole thing
i'm the free i'm the free spirit i'm i
want to let's go here let's go travel i
want to go places and she was just like
no we have to hammer down and buckle
down so that's pretty much it that's
what i started jumping on and uh
drinking the kool-aid yeah so when you
start working you're like got to do it
yeah every emergency we cashflowed got
him a little bit more through the door
it sounds like y'all have been living
emergency to emergency for the last
however many years what was it like
finally i mean y'all went from making
getting by to making stupid money what's
it like
really crossing that financial threshold
but then all of a sudden you've got her
saying
gotta k hey we gotta keep grinding gotta
keep grinding
that's gotta be hard right
it's so hard but it's like to look at it
having her being like we're going to be
debt-free we're going to live we can go
wherever we want once we're debt-free we
can go wherever we want we can do
whatever we want once we're debt-free
giving up the jeep for him i think was
the hardest part oh your soul is cheap
yes
and we sold it under 3 000 we still had
to pay off 3 000 when we sold it
upside down on it how much how much did
it sell for
uh it went for about 22 it was pretty
all the crazy um so it went for about 22
and we still owed 27 on it
so it was rough
ouch
okay but it's gone and now we get them
on to the next thing and the other next
thing and onto the next thing
and but i i i think john was recognizing
something that i saw too and the way you
all were talking about this you went
from a place where most of your life
money had happened to you
and now you started happening to it
money started yes you kind of went over
the edge and you went now we're in
control by god yes this stuff's not
gonna boss me around i'm gonna boss it
around exactly so i was in a place of my
life when this all started where i was
literally paying 45 on a credit card to
get it down from that maximum to buy
groceries or put gas in the car and then
it would max back out and then i'd pay
the next one off because that was the
one that was due that month and it was
not paycheck to paycheck it was credit
card payment to credit card payments
hide the p yes exactly i had to pay
under a shell what is it
for two folks who who've never
experienced this
what's what's
explain in your own words what does it
feel like on the other side of this
thing like you're completely now that
you're free i'm
weightless yeah but i i literally have
no stress on my shoulders i'm like
whatever
like oh i i can go here
we came to nashville like oh let's go to
nashville like okay let's go no problem
whereas i'm confused and stressed out
and trying to figure out what to do now
that i have managed to accomplish all
the little bullet points in my list and
it's amazing but it's like all of a
sudden looking at baby step three and it
happened so quickly and now we're into
3b trying to save for a house and it's
just kind of a what's next it's wild
yeah you're you're you've done amazing
incredible because here's what happened
um you didn't just get your money
straight you transformed
the way you look at it the way you think
about it there's a heart transformation
that occurred just looking at the two
you can see it on your face you can see
in your body language it's impressive
you guys are heroes you did some really
hard work is what i'm saying thank you
this is i can see it i mean some people
are just like oh we're going to do this
thing
but you guys went from
we're in control that's right and that's
from i'm just i'm going to keep running
this business no matter what no matter
what no matter what to
i got to look in the mirror and say
what's reality here and i got to do
something different project manager
hey i don't know how you figured out how
to that
making more money delivering people than
beer but congratulations on that thank
you well done but now hey now you're
going to please delivering people full
of beer that's right
very similar but now you can decide if a
job comes by and you're like some of my
gut says i'm not i'm gonna pass you can
pass exactly right
totally you could pass that's freedom
that's freedom man i don't have to worry
about sitting back and being like oh do
i i have to go to work today yeah i can
now go no i'm going to pass that tour
off or i'm going to pass that that
project off you know awesome those
aren't people i think i want to work
with this week yeah right
i like down playing it because he went
through three job changes trying to get
there he went from beer delivery to
tours on the road and wanted to come
back for family when we had that then
attempted his dream at firefighter we
did a lot of ken coleman listening to in
this and realized he wanted the money
and went back into entertainment and so
he really really threw everything out
and started over yes both of you did
yeah it was powerful it's incredible
guys
i love it we got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you that is the next
chapter in your story for sure no doubt
you are on track to do that and uh we'll
give you another copy of total money
makeover you can give it to someone to
sit on their shelf and five years from
now they'll pull it off at exactly the
right time right it is the uh the
the world's best-selling uh coffee table
table coaster holds lots of coffee cups
all over america until just the right
moment when it opens up so proud of you
guys very very very well done good stuff
and the kiddos names and ages i
understand they're sitting off to the
side yes they are we have ryder who's
three and liliana who is two months oh
fun very very cool all right it's mike
and cat with a complete transformation
while they pay off 206
thousand dollars in 31 months making
from 67 to 256.
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
three two
one
[Applause]
i love it
this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality
my co-host today
open phones at
825-5225
buffett is quoted as saying he wouldn't
take all the bitcoin in the world for 25
[Laughter]
that might be a bit of an indictment
folks i don't know we've been telling
you not to buy that stuff from day one
well dave anybody over the age of 58 is
clearly out of touch as a dinosaur and
doesn't know what they're doing and even
if you happen to be one of the richest
men in the world um
because of your financial
acumen acumen but
aside from that um idiot yeah he's an
idiot he doesn't know what he's doing
and and the fact that bitcoin's gone
from what fifty thousand to
thirty two
it's happened a rough few weeks twenty
minutes it's like
when when you're on the back end of the
largest uh bull run i don't know
on the planet's history and
people started creating imaginary things
to sell it's awesome and then all of a
sudden when gas is expensive and food is
expensive
imaginary things aren't so fun anymore
oh the unicorns come crashing down turns
out the uh nfts and the bitcoins are
imaginary
virtual means not really sorta kinda
almost
if i virtually send my wife flowers she
doesn't like it
i meant to but they didn't quite get
there
all right andrew's in atlanta georgia hi
andrew welcome to the ramsay show
hey how are you guys doing better than i
deserve what's up
all right so
um i have about fifteen hundred dollars
in credit card debt i'm cutting it down
not using that credit card anymore
but my question is i have sixteen
hundred and ninety four dollars in
interest-free
credit card debt it's interest-free for
33 more months it's equipment for
my music stuff i'm a musician and i do
stuff like that so
i was just wondering what should i
attack first
what should i do with that interest-free
debt should i just pay the payments till
it's done or just pay it
off okay
well so you have sixteen hundred in debt
and you have how much other debt
uh that's that's the only date i have
you only have sixteen hundred dollars in
debt that's your all your that's
any kind of debt you have a student loan
card debt
other credit cards no student loans new
car debt so i get a paid off car
so total with the interest rate and one
with interest i have about three
thousand dollars in that okay
all right and your household income is
what
uh i make about sixteen hundred or
sixteen thousand a year
okay with that that's including
music stuff and my part-time job as well
i'm a full-time student so oh okay
there's that okay because i was getting
ready to say your job sucks okay
um a full-time job making 16k puts you
at the poverty level so we don't want to
call that a career track okay
so we need to so what are you going to
do when are you getting out of school
what's your plan
i've got about two years left in school
i'm still at home so i don't have any
rent
i don't have i don't have a mortgage or
anything like that after that um
what are you studying graduating
uh marketing good okay so i want to go
into sales right so you're a college
student that lives at home with three
thousand dollars in debt
and how is school paid for
my father pays for that very nice okay
are you running up are you buying music
equipment are you playing shows on the
weekend trying to make it or is it just
a hobby
no yeah that i mean that was that's the
dream but i also want a backup plan
because i don't want to you know go move
up to nashville and uh
you know
not make it and be stuck i'd be stuck at
that point
how do you get the next country music
star's attention in nashville
uh waiter yeah so um
uh
all right
[Applause]
okay
num
number one you got a good overall plan
number two if you're making sixteen
hundred dollars or seventeen thousand
dollars a year you should pay this debt
off with no way out of pocket expenses
to mount anything very very quickly
would you agree with me that you're
gonna be done with the entire amount of
debt within three to six months is that
doable it is isn't it
yeah yeah i don't think so okay and so
really the interest rate doesn't matter
because you're going to be done in three
to six months now what we teach to
answer your question technically andrew
is to list your debts smallest to
largest
and uh sounds like they're about the
same size
regardless of interest rate pay minimum
payments on
everything but your smallest debt attack
the smallest debt first regardless of
interest rate so the fact that it's a
zero percent interest does not impress
me does not change the order in which i
pay it off i would pay off the smallest
one first regardless of the interest
rate because i want you to have the
emotional advantage of traction
seeing that you're starting to win
rather than living off of these credit
cards you're putting them under your
heel and grinding them
and being done with them and that's the
big thing but it sounds like these are
very similar
i mean if they're both
seventeen hundred dollars each
then then you got three thousand dollars
total then you know just uh you can put
whichever one you want first but be done
with the whole thing in six months but
let's just say you had ten different
debts and one of them was a thousand one
almost ten thousand uh
but the the uh the one thousand was
interest free would i still put it first
yes i would because i want you to get
the traction the advantage of this
psychological income of winning it's
called hope
and it causes people to continue to move
through this and that's how
we at ramsey have gotten more people out
of debt than probably any other
organization on the planet
at least currently operating and andrew
let me let me speak to you here
there is a
gibson flying v
electric guitar
that i've been eyeballing for like six
months
and i can afford it but my wife and i
have made some goals and some plans and
so i'm holding off i'm holding off and
now instagram listens to me and they
just send me these pictures of the
guitar and another one and another one
you're going to have to not buy music
equipment for a season just stop
you think you need a new thing for this
and a new gotta have that you don't need
it there's no end to it there's it just
will continue to consume you and i'm in
the middle of
that myself any people that play music
have an addictive problem for their
instruments
music people car people gun people like
it just happen so
you got to stop buying equipment say i'm
not going to buy another thing piece of
gear for another year and then i'm going
to get out of debt wait man if i need
another gun that's different that's
right that's right
don't get leave the cars alone right my
car is alone man yeah no no it's the
same thing you get you get you get to
where and the truth is there's almost
nothing in america that we buy that
qualifies as a need
very few almost everything we buy
qualifies as a want
very few i mean we pretty much are all
over fed and have too many clothes
and we pretty much all have a place to
sleep so food shelter clothing
transportation we got it covered you
know i mean it's not an issue
and so that that's not the problem in
america now there's nothing wrong with
spending money on once but we just tell
folks to be really careful and be
emotionally mature enough to say
that is a want right and once
for sure you pay cash for and for sure
they've got to go in line with your
overall goal yep yeah yeah so one of the
issues that rachel cruz talks about a
lot and i do too as well we're talking
about teaching kids about money is
teaching them
contentment
to learn to sit in what you have and
being good with it um and you know that
how far you could go in the music
business with the music equipment you
already have is amazing yep that's right
and without ever buying another thing
uh it's amazing and uh how
you know i if i could just get that if i
could just get that that's a
discontentment the advertisers and the
marketers job is to create psychological
dissonance
discomfort
in you so that you feel i will be
comfortable when i'll be satiated when
i get that next thing and and you know
that that's the driving force of the
most marketed to advertised to culture
in the history of
mankind in the history of the human race
and you live right square in the middle
of it and so do i
we see four to eight thousand
advertisements a day
there are advertisements in the bathroom
for god's sakes on the front and the
back of the door they're everywhere
ridiculous you know and so
you're not getting away from it and so
what you have to learn is the spiritual
and emotional
psychological discipline
to say
no no it's a complete sentence not doing
it no
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's john dolone co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsay show where dad
is dumb cash is king and the paid off
home mortgage has taken the place of the
bmw as the status symbol of choice i'm
dave ramsey your host number one
best-selling author and ramsey
personality dr john deloney is my
co-host today as we answer your question
about your life and your money open
phones at 825-5225
we help people build wealth do work that
they love
and create real
relationships jacob is with us jacob is
in flint michigan hi jacob how are you
hello i'm doing well good how are you
great man how can we help
well my wife and i are followers of your
plan we've paid off all our debt but for
our mortgage
uh but our house burned down this last
saturday oh no man
what happened
uh i'm not sure yet the fire department
thinks it started in the garage
i was the only one home at the time my
wife and kids were out of town
grandparents so i'm uninjured you know
we're okay we'll be doing all right it's
just total loss
i think so you know i'm no expert but i
think it's a total replacement i mean we
got a few things out after the fire was
out but they're all smoke damaged be
damaged
man i've sat in people's front yard with
my arm over the shoulder while we
watched their house burn and the and the
firefighters are there and
that's a traumatic moment man i'm sorry
that happened
i'm real sorry that happened dude
i'm glad you're saying i'm glad you're
safe
yeah the uh the uh cliche thing to say
as well everybody's okay yeah i know
unless you're home man all your stuff's
gone man that's just your memories your
pictures your
thing things keepsakes and valuables i'm
so sorry
thank you how can we help you walk
through this
well
i guess my question is a little broad i
just i never expected this i hadn't
really thought about it and i i want to
move through this with wisdom
you know so
is there a is there a ramsey way of
moving through a house fire
uh who who is your homeowner's insurance
with
state auto
okay all right
i don't have experience with that
particular brand one way or the other um
you don't have to be unkind but you're
gonna have to be very very tough
okay because the uh the in the
adjuster's job is to minimize the size
of the claim
and he or she works for the insurance
company not for you
okay
you may have to involve a lawyer to get
proper payout you might you could also
involve what's called a public adjuster
meaning you hire an adjuster on your
side of the negotiation that walks you
through every one of the details and
they'll they'll cost a lot but they
usually make you more than they cost you
if they're good at what they do um if
you smell trouble immediately run to one
of those two
okay but don't start with the naive
thing that the insurance company loves
you and they want to take care of you
none of that is true
right and d do you have um most
homeowners policies have
you know if it's a total loss then it's
going to be x number of dollars to
replace the home and then there's going
to be some money to give you a place to
live while you're waiting right do you
have you gone through your policy to
find out where you stand
yes yeah i saw our limit for
uh structure
and then our limit for contents and then
we've got some covering housing okay
okay well immediately get your housing
done get the families you know uh
emotionally solid in a place to live
where we're not living in a hotel room
as quick as you can because you're gonna
be here a while um then the second thing
i would tell you to do just from this is
just from experience it's not
necessarily a ramsey thing it's just
having again like john having walked
through this with other people
um start making everybody in the family
start making lots and lots and lots of
lists
of everything you can think of that was
in that house
lots of lists
and you're never done making this list
you just keep making it and you don't
let them rush you
to settlement
unless it's at the max that you're going
to get anyway if they want to write your
checks for the max
on the house and on the contents well
you don't have to do a lot of lists
they're just going to write they just
said okay we're going to cover it
but usually you've got to create some
kind of proof
and then they want to argue about every
freaking little item on that list as to
how much it's depreciated
and all of this and so i wish i could
give you good news and say this was
going to be an easy thing
now there's two different sets of trauma
that's happened here one is the fire and
all that they all the emotions that go
with that and the loss and then there's
another set of trauma and that's gonna
be dealing with the insurance company uh
it's you know i wish i could tell you it
wasn't going to be that if it's not
um
then you found the best insurance
company on the planet but i can tell you
the vast majority of them are an
absolute
pain in the butt to go through this
process with and so you've got to
uh
take control of the narrative take
control of the discussion by constantly
pushing constantly raising constantly
moving the timeline along and and you
know well we're going to use our uh
you know contractor well maybe we're not
that's right there's nothing in the
policy that says we're going to use your
contractor uh so maybe we're going to
use my contractor and so i'm going to
control the narrative i'm going to
control
the discussion and the decisions i'm not
going to assume
um i mean i don't want you to be mean to
him again but but you need to be taught
you have to be tough you have to be
really really strong
if you need to be mean you can but uh
but at first you just need to be really
really strong and don't
make the assumption that just because
they're nice
or just because they're kind or they
they speak slow or low
that which they're trained to do that
that's gonna
immediately mean you don't come up a
hundred thousand bucks short when this
is all over of what you should have
gotten because you didn't lean into the
details in the process i would this is
gonna sound like um
uh being cliche here and so i would tell
you this if you and i were just hanging
out and i didn't work here
i've heard of one time that somebody had
a
a
a disaster it was during the tornadoes
in nashville a couple years ago and my
buddy was had just switched his
homeowners insurance to xander and he
lost everything and he said it was an
extraordinary experience
it was from start to finish they helped
took care of him and we had dinner and
his brand new they rebuilt the house
from the floor up dug the whole thing
out and he said it was a
like start to finish was a great
experience but zander wasn't the
insurance company xander was the broker
they were the broker and they stepped in
and also fought on his behalf yeah
that's you gotta you got somebody in
your corner when you got broken
and they
you know again they do that because of
our relationship yeah and so that's
really incredible that makes a lot of
difference but in most cases you know
you're on your own kitchen table yeah
yeah you're just trying to make lists
and you're trying to figure this out and
you're trying to consider the legalities
and
everything else and so don't
you know
and i would just readily you know keep
bringing up to the adjuster look if we
can't come to a reasonable
process on this then we're gonna have to
involve an attorney or we're gonna have
to involve a public adjuster if i if you
and i can't manage this project to get
to a reasonable result then i'm gonna
have to bring in outside people to push
you around if i can't if you and i can't
work this and so you just very calmly
just stay in their grill
the whole time it's going to be two
years
it'll be a two year process
sorry about that sorry brother that's
that's uh we can help anyway you holler
at us this is the ramsay show
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at
825.5225 we appreciate you being here
well john last time we played your
questions for humans conversation cards
uh you found out uh
my favorite tv shows downton abbey not
true
and uh that there was a murder in my
family and uh so these cards are selling
i'm proud of them yeah they're selling
like crazy man
it's a lot of fun people are uh having
the it gives them an opportunity an
entrance into a conversation which they
may have not had in a couple years so
it's good so um we pulled some other
cards out of here out of the friends
deck here okay all right
so um
let's see here
what's the
what's your favorite cheat meal that
you'll always love no matter how much
money you make
hmm
cheat meal
i'd probably be chocolate doughnuts i
guess but
that's not a
from a certain place nah just pizza
mine is i kept hearing about it over and
over day after day and finally one night
sheila was out of town i got up in the
car i drove by myself this is years ago
to a local taco bell and i said one
dorito taco please listen
listen man i took one bite of the dorito
taco and i thought america's gonna be
okay like if we came up with this we're
gonna make it yeah that your belly is
glowing oh yeah oh dude that's
radioactive yeah
not good for you but i'm telling you no
it's not only not good for you it's bad
for
you all right what's the best concert
you've ever been to and why
um
i well i mean i've been to like five
eagles concerts yeah so including hotel
california just the other day how was
that
it's good yeah i mean the boys are
getting older yeah i mean
vince can still sing and they can they
don't miss a lick on a guitar i mean joe
walsh may be one of the best guitars in
the world he can jam so convinced man
and vince right there with him but uh
their their vocals are
aging out a little they were really
really good though they're 90 there
yeah still and vince is 100 there he's
better glenn fry than glenn frye was
probably
all right and uh who's the worst boss
you ever had and why uh
i guess the guy that came in and told me
to f and get my fn desk cleaned out and
get the effing out of there and i still
don't know why i got fired
it still haunts you yeah you're just
driving along the highway died so i
don't even i'll never know why i got
fired i don't i probably deserve to get
fired i just don't know what i did
i still to this day don't um but that
would drive me crazy yeah i would need
that closure i'm not insecure that that
well i mean it i would want to know like
what did i do a long time ago it was 40
years ago but you know but uh so
consequently people that work at ramsey
always know
why they got five very clear never any
doubt as to what happened you know
you may not like it you may not agree
with it but you will know oh and you're
also not going to be surprised yeah i
was surprised i didn't see it coming uh
you know and so there's that that goes
with the two so yeah that has to be the
worst boss right
yeah
what about you what about your worst
boss
that's tough to answer in front of all
these people
um they might be listening
i had mine has the benefit of being dead
yeah yours is dead you can say whatever
you want um i gosh i've i'll tell you
this it sounds so cheesy i have been
so fortunate to have some of the
greatest supervisors ever
there's one that uh get him a dorito
taco
no we don't want we don't need that kind
of digestive issues on the radio no but
i i mean those digestive issues there
was there was one supervisor i had that
had some significant integrity issues
that ultimately um that person left
and and so i ended up staying but that
person left and that was that was tough
for me as a young professional
it it uh was a baptism by fire like
i i've had that happen when i've worked
at places but even more so even while
i've owned the place that
um that someone leaves
and uh as a leader i've told leaders
this i've taught this in ontario
leadership that someone leaves and you
go okay this person enough already yeah
this is we've tried everything we've
negotiated about this we've tried to
correct the behavior and but you're
worried because they're real popular
with the gang and the gang doesn't know
the whole story yeah and so when you
eject them you think you're going to get
a rebellion right
and when you hit a jack but what i've
discovered happens is that the gang does
know yeah and you have what i call the
uh uh the uh wizard of oz syndrome where
that scene in the wizard of oz where
dorothy is throws the water on the
wicked witch it towards the end oh yeah
and the old original is right and it's
like what a whale with a whale and she
smelled you know she melts and goes
through a trap door on the floor and
there's a hair thing and then the oompa
loompa guys are standing around the
little poodle looking guys right with
their curvy knives
and they're like
that's right and uh you think they're
gonna turn these knives on dorothy
because they just she just killed their
boss yeah and there's this pregnant
pause in the movie like a three beat you
know and it's like oh no they're gonna
turn this is dorothy's toast right here
and then they all drop to one knee and
go all hail dorothy that's right and
that's what they do to the leader who
removes toxic stuff from the
organization thank you so much the team
goes all hail the leader he's actually a
leader he actually she actually knew
what the flip was going on so yeah
that's a it's a very valuable leadership
lesson to remember that you might have a
wizard of oz moment when you remove
the uh toxic tina from the organization
so uh or who whoever it is or toxic tony
it could be i don't know either way
somebody has to be somebody with a t
because we have to alliterate so
questions for human cards are on sale
they're part of the 10 sale at ramsey
right now go to ramseysolutions.com
there's a lot of stuff a lot of our
best-selling books etc on sale for the
uh unbelievable price of ten dollars and
lots of number one best-selling books
the questions for human cards there
check it all out it's absolutely
the best time to get a deal and if you
haven't heard you can enter the ramsey
cash giveaway for a chance to win up to
three thousand dollars no purchase
necessary must be 18 or older to win to
enter the giveaway go to
ramseysolutions.com
giveaway anna is in pittsburgh hi anna
welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave hi john thanks for taking my
call sure what's up
okay so i am currently teaching fpu at
my church and this week's lesson was on
insurance so it really got me thinking
about my parents and they do not have
long-term care insurance
and i've talked to them about it a
couple times before they just don't
really seem to be interested
so i just want some advice on
what to do i just want to make sure
they're protected and that i'm protected
as well
well you're not in jeopardy
unless she's the one that's going to
have to take care of her well if she
chooses not to write the check she's not
in jeopardy yeah
so you know
there's no law that says that you have
to write the check for the nursing home
if they don't do what they're supposed
to do
so they'll just have to work it out but
uh
uh so you're you're technically not in
jeopardy now
uh and and if someone refuses your
advice on getting the proper coverage
and then later on once your money
instead
um i think they're disqualified at that
point so
um but uh you know so how do you
convince mom and dad
to do anything it's almost impossible
you really can't and because you've
heard me say it before anna it's the
powdered butt syndrome once someone has
powdered your butt they don't want your
advice on money or sex
and so your parents just aren't going to
listen to you about these things it's
weird i i had this conversation with my
parents here's how i approached it i
said i want to know what y'all's plan is
and what is the plan for
if something was to happen to one of you
and this was a broader like hey let's
talk about the will let's talk about
what is the plan if something happens
and that um i've got great
parents and wise parents and they that
sparked a conversation of
oh we need to come up with a x y z plan
which they got us long-term care
insurance i think for christmas they
they got it and then told all of us as
their kids like hey this is really
expensive so merry christmas y'all
aren't going to have to
have it they got it for themselves for
themselves christmas present to you yeah
to us so you don't have to deal with it
so hey mom and dad you want to give me a
christmas present that'd be one way to
approach it there you go have some but
and i i i had the exact same experience
i had a relative that um
actually came and asked my advice and i
told them all the reasons that they
needed to get long-term care insurance
they didn't do it
18 months later
the wife was diagnosed with early onset
alzheimer's
and they didn't have the coverage and
you can't get the coverage then it's
like getting
can't get you know car insurance after
the car wreck it's not possible so
uh i would just begin to talk to them
but i just say i'm concerned i love you
but you can't make them do it and you're
gonna be really disappointed in your
life if you keep trying to
get people to do stuff they don't want
to do
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsay personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today elizabeth is with us she is in
sacramento hi elizabeth i see on my
screen you're completely debt-free way
to go
yes i am and it is so incredible
exciting i love knowing when i go to the
store and i spend money it is mine
love and love it repayment
yep me too how much you pay off
65 000. cool how long did this take you
five years good for you and your range
of income during that time
well when i finally got serious about
getting out of debt it started 11.86
and i finished it that just got a
premade wrote promotion last month and
about 50 000 a year good for you wow
good for you that's amazing so what do
you do
i work at a hotel i'm now i'm a
supervisor
cool good for you supervising what
supervising the front staff assisting
guests with any opportunities they may
have with the hotel
great very cool and what kind of uh
debt was the 65
000. was a combination of
twenty five thousand five hundred and
student loans
ten thousand of the federal government
and uh twenty nine thousand five hundred
between two credit cards wow
way to go how old are you
i am 44.
so what happened when you were 39 that
was your wake-up call
ugly divorce and
custody issues
and not being able to provide for myself
or my son and just getting myself
more and more debt with credit cards to
make ends meet
was sick and tired of being sick and
tired and i ended up having to let go of
my fully furnished two-bedroom apartment
because i just couldn't afford the rent
increases
what was originally
1100 went to 1800 you know within a year
sure that's just ridiculous so
you know it's hard to tell my son i'm
sorry i can't do that for you baby i
can't afford that i'm sorry
and i just didn't want my debt to make
choices for me anymore so i let go of my
two-bedroom apartment
moved in with a christian family and
friends as a sublet put everything i had
in a 10 by 10 storage unit started
selling it all
i'm glad my son didn't think he was next
my jewelry all my furniture
everything it's now down to like a 5x10
storage unit and i'm still selling stuff
look at you i took
odd jobs over time in fact i volunteered
to work the graveyard shift because it
initially paid more an hour
been with the same company six years and
i
took advantage of every free thing that
they offered as their their team members
and employees and i love my company
because they have been a huge part of
that journey that's cool as well as my
accountability partners and making a
budget that is just
too crucial the accountability and the
budget
how did you run into the ramsey stuff
i had first heard about it actually from
my ex-husband um
let's see about
15 years ago i was diagnosed with a
brain tumor and our spring or a portion
of the medical costs and it did it to be
like forty thousand dollars
and uh
that was a huge amount of money for us
and we were already in debt and we're
like well we need to do something
different because what we're doing is
just not working we're just getting into
more holes
so we bought the dvds and did the
classes at home and just as we were
digging ourselves out of the of the
credit cards then
we got a divorce and so i dug myself
back into more credit cards and more
debt with the divorce costs and
everything
and uh
you know i ended up taking fpu twice
through my different my church and
with this third time of being sick and
tired of being sick and tired it's like
i'm gonna stop being dave-ish
and be gazelle intense i want to slay
the dragon of my debt
and it sounds like in the process you
just hit ctrl alt delete on your whole
life
everything was turned around but they've
been some of the best worst experiences
of my life and i will never go back to
credit cards
lending borrowing money nothing
what was it like i can't think of
industry
i mean there's there's so many that were
hit hard in the last couple years but
one of the hardest hit was the
hotel industry what was the stress like
trying to keep this thing going
well i'm fortunate to say we were
attached to a casino a tribal casino in
northern california
so while our industry we did put pause
for six weeks during the pandemic that i
had already started my
thousand dollars step one emergency fund
and knowing that i had that in my back
pocket
it just and i was already halfway
through my debt journey that was just i
was sailing through it i was like i'm
going to take the time and just relax
and enjoy and
not work for six weeks and
then get back after used that
yankee we reopened and
i mean we're still having issues as a
hotel with staffing and you know clean
you know we try and keep everything
super clean
the guests may not always understand
that
pre pre-pre and post-pendec expectations
can't you know they're different
right but uh well good for you i'm so
i'm so
there's a few fewer harder things than a
single mom who says all right i gotta i
just gotta do it this all over and i got
to start with myself and i got to make
this thing happen and you did and it's
it's just it's inspiring it's incredible
very well done we're proud of you
good job elizabeth me too
thank you thank you what do you tell
people the key to getting out of debt is
make a plan i recommend the ramsey pro
steps but if they want to follow
something else just find something that
works for you make a plan
get an accountability partner and budget
and then if you can cut that budget i
i had you know my bare minimum budget
and then i was like because i don't
drive for medical reasons i was like i
can't afford to lift an uber
so i cut my lift an uber out of my life
i started walking more taking public
transit and i with my county partner
figured out
that i can pay my friends hey how'd you
like to make some extra money
driving me around town
and so thankfully when the bus is not
available and it
i can't walk home with two bricks with
the groceries
they uh
they graciously pick me up and lyft and
uber is now
a distant third option convenient option
but you know it's not my first choice
yeah
that's powerful yeah dude you get
creative when you want out and you got
to work it and you worked it oh yeah
very very well done hey we got a copy of
baby steps millionaires for you that's
the next chapter in your story you are
on your way you have uh turned the
corner for sure you've climbed your way
up out of the valley and uh you are
heading across the top of the mountain
well done
uh also a copy of total money makeover
you can give it away to somebody there
in the hotel or some friend that's been
helping you with driving around maybe
you can start a holy ruckus in their
life that'd be good stuff oh
i've already done that i've had like
several copies with your ten dollar
sales and i hand them out like candy
first taste is free well thank you thank
you very very much very well done
all right it's elizabeth in sacramento
65 000 paid off in five years
making a
11.86 all the way to 50 000 bucks a year
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
three two one i'm debt-free
wow
[Music]
yeah just in case you're sitting there
making 82 000 a year with two car
payments whining
that you can't figure out a way to do
this along comes elizabeth and mike
drops on your head
right or you're living in some giant
metropolitan city and you think that the
world should bring the rent down for you
because you deserve to live in this town
along comes elizabeth and says i'll take
the night shift and i can't live in the
1800s so i'm moving down to the movement
moving out i'll live in this other place
i'll put all my stuff in a box and sell
it
good for her just because i'm in
sacramento i don't get a pass on math
i'm going to do what it takes
it's a it's a different
there's something about people when they
get up above a problem and stand on it
rather than laying under it yes and it's
victor versus victim man and we all can
do both yeah we all have a tendency to
both yeah
but it is a conscious decision to get
above it and go no
not today problem today i own you
big brain tumor
ugly divorce single mom
making 11 bucks
to i'm turning this whole thing around
it's never too late to start over yeah
and i got friends and i got a great
place to work taking care of me game on
and family helping me and a christian
family my church taking me in
letting me sublet oh my gosh people all
around are helping her
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
caitlin is with us on the line open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five dr john delony ramsey
personality
is my co-host today caitlin's in
washington dc hi caitlin how are you
hey good thank you for helping me out
with my question sure how can we help
okay so my husband and i just recently
relocated from his job and we moved from
our my dream house and our dream
location to um this area
to this area so
why did you leave why did you all
destroy your dream
it it's um just for his first job it's
better it's better
it's a better job so
okay anyway
so how can we know it was good that was
good and it's not that bad it really
isn't um it's growing on me but so my
question is um we're going to close on
our home we're selling um at the end of
this month
we
are selling it for 9.25 and we bought it
for 5.69
we owed around 228 on it
so when all is said and done we should
make about 680.
here we have purchased a townhome which
is much smaller it's really nice but
it's not you know our forever home
so my question is
when we do get that money
should we pay off the town home we would
then become totally debt-free um we owe
about okay
okay we owe about 311 on this now for to
pay that off and then
our
our hope is to build
we're not sure where we kind of want to
see where we're going to be at
so we just want to make the right
decision and then possibly keep this and
then maybe rent it out in the future
only if you can build with cash and keep
that with cash
okay if you have to sell that to keep
from taking out a mortgage
then you will sell it and you will sell
it okay okay but um but i'm going to go
ahead and pay it off now you've got the
peace and the stability of no debt
you've got this tremendous cash flow
with this wonderful new job
and you're going to use all of it to
pile up cash in addition to what you've
got left over from the sale the dream
home back at the other location and all
of that is moving towards building
another dream home
another home that you might you guys
adore and love and hopefully between the
sale of the townhouse and the cash that
you save and have saved from the other
house you can pay cash for the new house
if you can do that and keep the paid for
townhouse as a rental fine
but again we're not going to keep the
how town house and then go borrow money
on your new place
because that's in effect borrowing money
to buy rental property and we're not
doing that
right
so that's your plan congratulations what
a big windfall it's that's a great man
yeah one
the bad news is you sold your dream
house the good news is you made bank on
it we're rich it's awesome that's
awesome serious well done
zach is in minnesota hi zach welcome to
the ramsay show
thanks thank you so much for taking my
call sure how can we help
so i am about to start a new career in
real estate and work my wife and i are
following your baby steps finally after
knowing them for so long you're finally
getting
the zealand sense on them my question is
because
real estate is commission only should i
should we
um build up our three to six months of
emergency fund before we really delve
into the debt snowballs no
but what you should do is you should
build an account not that you don't call
an emergency fund but that you use to
supplement your lack of income
that's different than an emergency
that's planning a career transition
and when i was in the real estate
business sometimes i had a month where i
made zero
and i might make 20 000 bucks the next
month
and so we always kept a separate fund
from our emergency fund that we had a
horrible name for it it was called the
hill and valley fund
when we were on the hill we set some
money back so when there was a valley
in other words if you were charting your
income and you saw hills and valleys
the hill and valley fund smoothed them
out does that make sense
yeah absolutely now here's the trick
six months in you should not need this
at all
you should be making more than you used
to make total
and you should never look badly but but
in your first six months your income is
going to be
at best volatile at worst non-existent
now is your wife work outside the home
she does she uh
is working at
a large department store while she is
finishing her master's degree
what is it you all are going to live on
um
we are well that's why i'm asking if we
should have
kind of some money stockpiled up because
she's
making about 2 800
a month um
before taxes can you live on that and so
yeah we can live on that okay if you can
live on her income then you don't have
to have a lot stockpiled and here's the
maybe i'm reading into this man but
if you can't afford six months of making
zero salary it might be you need to
pause on taking a 100 commission job if
y'all can't eat
or you're gonna have to work on this job
and get after it all day and then go
find something and at night and drive so
that y'all have some food yeah you know
what i mean 2 800 if you guys can break
even on that then you don't need a fund
okay
if you if she can make enough you can
live on your wife's income till you get
your real estate business going there's
no
i mean it's just you just have to do
that you can't go up and go well we run
up 30 000 in credit card debt while i
started my real estate no
no that would be stupid we're not using
the credit cards anymore yeah but i mean
you that's what people do and that's why
i'm saying it out loud so yeah we don't
want to go that route so you only need
as big a fund as her income won't cover
for six months
and that's as big of fun as you need but
it's not really an emergency fund it's a
plan to transition
and uh so an emergency is an unexpected
event
this is expected we're we're expecting
this we can predict it
and then get out there and kick kick
butt and take names and let's go make a
bunch of money in the real estate
business so being straight commission in
and of itself does not require you have
an extra fund
um it might lean you towards the
six-month side in that three to six
months
spectrum
but uh
you know if you if you're straight
commissioner and you make 300 000 a year
and you used to make 40 000 a year you
don't have a problem yeah you know and
so the the fact that something is
commissioned isn't the issue sometimes
if something's commissioned and it means
you don't make any money
it's not making money that's the issue
not the commissions
so um being self-employed is not the
issue the issue is being self-employed
not making money
so that that's that's what comes up in
people in these situations
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five dr john dolone's
new book own your past
change your future last week was number
one in the nation in
uh on all the best seller lists that
matter
and uh pretty cool so thank you guys we
appreciate you in america the book is a
not so complicated approach to
relationships mental health and wellness
it has done very very well it's
continuing to sell
very fast in a world where we need to
have
some framework for coping
with the things we have gone through and
or are going through
and every one of us have things we go
through and or are going through no one
is an exception to that and and we've
had a
culture-wide experience in the past
24-36 months of this culture-wide stress
and anxiety level and this gives you
just some you know okay that guy over
there is usually not
a complete but
so he must really be scared yeah
and it gives you a different way of
different framework of looking at things
and if you own your past
you say that's there that really
happened then you can change your future
that's right and we're heading into some
some strong headwinds with some some
negative financial information and we're
heading into some unstable political
it's going to be the rest of our lives
it's a thing will come up and then mom
will get sick and we'll get lose a job
life happens
so i love it's a framework man for how
to do life well
it's a way of it gives me skills tools
in my belt for we give you tools in your
belt for your career tools and your belt
for your money tools and your belt for
your relationships and your mental
wellness and that's what we do here at
ramsey and we do it here on the ramsey
show the phone number is triple eight
eight two five five two two five if you
want to participate
i am dave ramsey your host and we'll be
back
[Music]
here you can find all of our shows with
the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
dr john deloney number one best-selling
author of the book own your past and
change your future
is my co-host today as we take your
calls about your life and your money
it is a free call at triple eight eight
two five five two two five here on the
ramsey show we help people build wealth
do work that they love
and create real
relationships
number two line is joseph calling from
savannah georgia to kick off this hour
what's up joseph
uh good afternoon gentlemen um
just uh where to call and
ask for some words of encouragement and
helped me as a to stave off losing
motivation i'm on baby step
number six
currently working two jobs and i've been
praying
for god to help me with
discernment to see if
i should continue working the two jobs
because the anxiety is just
it's getting to be a lot and
even though sending that big chunk to
the mortgage company every month feels
good
so you are debt free except your house
correct you're putting 15 of your income
into retirement
correct why are you working two jobs
uh because when i started this uh baby
step seven was always the goal um yeah
but we didn't teach you to stay gazelle
intense
after four we said move from intense to
intentional
you go from sprint to marathon when you
go into four five and six
so how many hours a week are you working
uh it's two full-time jobs
okay what do you make at your main job
i'm making 80.
and what do you make of the second job
60. and what do you owe on your house
uh 240. are you married
no
you have kids
yes
you have custody of the kids
50
and uh i'm covering tuition
what does a second job consist of
uh business analysts so both both work
both jobs are remote
so you're never off cut the second job
in half or by 75 or quit it completely
today
you don't need that 60k
dave and i both know a bunch of
millionaires who crossed that finish
line and they looked around and had
nothing
that's why we teach it the way we do
yeah
the you know you've
you know you've taken gazelle intensity
and put it over into those last several
baby steps and it's not sustainable yeah
the human body the human spirit you're
gonna you're running out of gas that's
why you're calling because you you're
gasping for air and i don't blame you
you're listen you're not afraid of hard
work and you're actually not a
workaholic you're just so goal driven
and focus driven that you've run you've
run yourself out of your own shoes
when was your divorce
uh 2018.
you still running
yes
yeah
you got to stop
because that shadow's chasing you and
chasing you and chasing you and as the
sun moves that shadow gets faster and
longer it's going to catch you there's
something that is a little bit
uh it feels like you're afraid if you
sit still you won't like what you hear
or see
am i wrong
um i think
being alone these last couple years um
god has been teaching me to
listen to myself so
i've appreciated being alone and taking
the time to reflect um
i think
i don't know when you had that time
listen listen
there is none zero there is no long-term
wellness there's no long-term
long-term healing there's no long-term
life with joy in it that is done in
isolation
and that it's done with this many hours
right
in the job
two full-time jobs is it it's not
sustainable you can do it for two or
three years and you have
all right because you busted through the
first several baby steps and that's fine
i don't i'm not afraid of hard work i'm
not afraid of telling people to go work
hard but um you know if i the way i
answer questions here joseph is i woke
up in your shoes i'm three years old out
of a divorce i got 50
of my time with my babies and uh all i
got left to do is knock out the mortgage
i'm currently putting 15 of my income
away i make 80. i could easily take that
60 dollar back to 20 and i'd have so
much free time i wouldn't know what to
do with it and that's what i would do
and then you you just kind of i want you
to take a deep breath and it feels like
cold mountain air in the morning coming
into your lungs that's called peace and
just feel it and that's what i would
want for you that's what i would want to
be if i were you
um
and so
i i kind of did something similar and
i'm not accusing you of this uh but but
uh when we went through bankruptcy
i worked like an absolute maniac the
other side of that because i was so
scared
and i didn't i didn't want to stop i
didn't want to i i didn't want to dial
it back and um
uh and it wasn't it wasn't a workaholism
it wasn't in that sense but but it was
just a running like john was saying and
so if i were in your shoes i'd dial it
back
yeah i think there's no question
when you two dial it back brother i want
you to
make a commitment to yourself i'm gonna
go walk i'm gonna go to the gym a few
times a week
and i'm gonna get a group of guys and
i'm gonna invite them over the house and
we're gonna i don't know what you're
into we're gonna watch fights we're
gonna watch don't watch golf on tv god
help you but we're going to get a group
of guys over together and we're going to
watch something we're going to do
something together and i'm going to
begin to build back relationships in my
life you had two years of being in
complete and total isolation that
anxiety alarm that you're feeling is
ringing off the wall because your body
is saying hey we're not we're not we're
not safe you called us because you
wanted us to tell you what you already
knew that's right
that happens a lot around here dan is in
coeur d'alene idaho hi dan welcome to
the ramsay show
how are you doing today great man what's
up
hey i'm 61 years old i will be in july
i i
just went through a divorce two years
ago
and ended up selling the house and
bought a holiday trailer to live in
because i'm not going to pay for another
mortgage
and i have 170 000
that's
130 in cash and the rest in the mutual
fund
but i'm trying to figure out what i
should do for retirement because
i have friends that are younger than me
they haven't
uh
one had a stroke in the he can't drive
anymore and
my health is not the greatest so trying
to figure out what to do
what's uh what's uh what's wrong with
your health
i just got screwed up guts
it's good getting a bad back so bad
combination
okay
well you're not gonna be lifting
anything for a living are you working
oh yeah i'm a truck driver which is
really not great for either oil
i would like to get out of it and retire
but that my plan was to get the house
all paid off and
and just get a part-time job and kind of
enjoy life and
that kind of went out the window so yeah
um jump on
ramseysolutions.com and hit the smart
investor pro button and find a
smartbester pro they can advise you on
helping you get some of that 170 000
invested it's sitting in a savings
account not making any money and also
set you up a roth ira and some other
things to get some investing going so we
get your nest egg up a little better so
you can relax here in the next couple
years
it sounds like other than that you're on
your way
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we talk about your life
and your money if you've taken financial
peace university you know
it's life-changing
it's hard to watch your friends and
family struggle with money when you know
there's a way you know there's hope
now you can actually help them
change their family tree just like you
did when you give them a ramsay plus
gift card it bundles everything that
they need to win with money into one
gift it includes financial peace
university
a year of the premium version of every
dollar the every dollar absolute
connects to your bank and now we've also
added unlimited group coaching from our
team of financial coaches so coaching
every dollar financial peace university
wow
a ramsey plus gift card listen to this
all of that that's that should be like
500 worth of stuff
99 bucks and that's a year's access
99 bucks that's a deal that's a hookup
man that's a d on
but okay but it's really it's it's this
is this is the best thing we do around
here and one of the best things we do
around here and man so ramsey solutions
dot com slash gift get a ramsey plus
gift card for just 99 bucks you can give
this to a friend maybe you know
somebody's getting ready to graduate
hello getting ready to get married it's
wedding and graduation season gift card
99 bucks get some everything
and uh here's the thing they can't throw
it in the um
back closet and not get it out for five
years because it's only good for a year
so they got to go do it and they can't
buy something stupid on amazon with that
gift card so get them a gift card it's
actually going to change their life you
mean their stupid stuff on amazon i've
bought my share of stupid stuff it
reminds me it goes like every you know
once a year this morning here's what you
bought this morning no not this not this
morning but it says if you don't want to
buy stupid stuff on amazon the best
thing to do stay away from rachel cruz
here's here's here's what you bought
last year and i look at and go
oh man i really needed i those specials
don't even know what that does but i hit
the button and got it delivered yeah
oh
all right david's in dallas hi david how
are you
hey dave and tom is great to talk to you
and pick your brains on something today
sure what's up
uh well i'm 56 um i've got 228 000 in
six different debts including two
student loans my wife's undergrad
and then my uh parent plus loan for my
kid who has been on your show doing a
debt-free screen back in 2018
um and then also master's work that i
did
and y'all are educated up around there i
hope you're making money what's your
household income
uh about 150. that's good okay actually
about 160 now come think of it
um so what i'm trying to figure out is
given
you know my age given the debt level um
is it wise for me just to stick with
baby step two
or to
go ahead and start putting some into
roth um to start making some headway
there what do you and your wife do for a
living tournament
we both work in education
she's a teacher and i work in i.t
what do you do in i.t
i'm a
director i manage email voicemail
telephone systems all the
my group handles everything that all the
end users touch
so you're making how much of the 160
about 102
are you allowed in your current contract
to take any side consulting gigs
yes good you need some
so here's
here's what
number one the answer your question is
no you don't need to go get a roth ira
the instead what you need is a vision
for paying off this debt very very
quickly so that you're not panicked
about the fact that you have no
retirement so what if i said let's go
completely out of our minds bizarre for
two years and be debt-free you guys both
are high intellect you're both very
intellectual people
and if you're not careful you're going
to think yourself out of a visceral
response to this problem which is the
fastest way out i want you to get so
pissed off that your eyes are bleeding
and your brain quits thinking and all
you do is go make money like a maniac
and get your income up at two and a
quarter and live on beans and rice and
you don't need to see the inside of a
restaurant unless you're working there
and if you even get on amazon again i'm
going to throw your computer in the
dadgum trash and oh by the way you're
not going on vacation you need to get
your button gear and get this mess
cleaned up that kind of emotion instead
of using intellect to fix this problem
because you use intellect to fix
everything because you're so freaking
smart
well if i were that smart i wouldn't be
in this
[Laughter]
hey man
you are both you are both highly
educated very analytical people am i
right
pretty much yeah and so you're trying to
figure out a way around this is why you
called
and instead i'm throwing dynamite in the
middle of this thing
blowing you up man well i mean i do pick
up uh stuff that's primarily in the fall
um
it goes basically from august through
january ish and and i'm trying to add to
it for the spring i mean i end up
picking up additional stuff through work
working games where i pick up you know
four to six thousand dollars a year
additional
i just think i'm talking about enough
i'm talking about fifty thousand yeah
that's five bucks i mean that's 50 bucks
a pop you you got to make more than that
i'm talking about 50 grand you're in an
industry where you can contract out and
manage it from your home while your wife
is asleep and go bananas that you're and
i want you to do this for very long
but but i want you to have no life so
that late so that very quickly you have
a life again because here's the thing
let's pretend that you lost your mind
and people thought you were crazy like
i'm describing and you guys just went
bananas you scorched earth on the
lifestyle and in two years you were free
at 58. how rich are you going to be
making by then probably 180 000 a year
without working crazy
and having no payments in the world for
the first time in your recent memory
you're going to have so much margin that
you're going to be able to throw so much
money you're you'll probably be worth in
excess of a million dollars by the time
you get to 65 starting at 58.
but you have this barrier in front of
you and you have two years of hell
to bust that barrier
can y'all do that
yeah
the only challenge we have is our our
daughter single parent of an infant
and having to care for her sometimes and
my wife having to juggle working late
sometimes but we can figure that piece
out
it can also be it can also be a really
challenging conversation
sitting down with your daughter saying
we're going to be able to we've got this
plan
which is going to benefit you and this
young granddaughter in the long run
exponentially more than scatter shot
babysitting here in the current
well no it's not that she works 7a 787p
and there is no daycare okay
that we found anyway we found
inexpensive daycare 45 bucks a day while
she is at work and while we're at work
but when we get home one of us is there
watching that doesn't mean that i can't
go ahead and work you know doing i.t
stuff etc so
so
here's the thing um
yeah there's a lot going on and you have
some barriers
the truth is though the best way to get
where you want to be not the barriers
the best way you well there are
obstacles uh there are things you have
to work through whatever it is you can
call them we can call them whatever we
want to call them but the best way to be
where you want to be
uh
nine years from today is what i just
described but think about it and go get
it done the highest probability
of you getting there in the shortest
amount of time is what i described
from all of my 30 years of doing this i
don't know a better way and it and it is
not a better way to limp into retirement
with three different kinds of student or
four different kinds of student loans
hanging around your neck and you've got
a half butt roth ira right and that's
where you'll be nine years from now if
you try to just short circuit this
system instead of punching this thing in
the nose
and but there's something that has to
happen inside of your
deep down where you growl that's not
your brain yes
it's the i've had it moment and you're
just howling at the moon and you're
going no more i've worked my butt off i
got this stupid parent plus loan i've
got this kid single with a single mom
one of my grandbabies and i love them
dearly but dead gum what a mess oh my
gosh and i gotta fight through this and
there's something you're just going to
double up your fist and just get after
it and that's the best way out of this
it's the fastest way out
and i don't know a better way
a modified version of that to tell you
if i did i would because it's gonna i'm
what i'm prescribing is a horrible two
years
i want you to have a miserable two years
so that the next 25 are excellent there
you go
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt-free
stage
kyle and corinne are with us hey guys
how are you great how are you better
than i deserve so good to have you where
do you guys live bellingham washington
bellingham washington bit of a hall to
nashville
well it's good to have you thank you for
joining us how much debt have you paid
off 273 thousand dollars
how long did that take about five years
good for you and your range of income
during that time about 92 to 140. good
what do you guys do for a living i'm a
police officer and i'm a part-time
speech-language pathologist very good
cool so five years and 273 000 in
bellingham washington was that your
house we're weird people
looking talking to weird people
yeah i love it very cool what's this
house worth right now it's around 7 50
probably
yeah 80 when that happens
i love it how old are you two i'm 39 i'm
38. not even 40 with a paid for
three-quarters of a million dollar house
yes y'all are y'all are truly weird
how much is in your 401k is your
retirement stuff uh enough to probably
tip us over to that everyday millionaire
status way to go baby steps millionaires
whoa
look at you you did it man and not even
40 years old no and by the way a police
officer and a part-time speech path
paid off their house before 40. not
brain scientists not they're not fixing
rockets actually you're fixing
neighborhoods which is harder right for
real but yes we're not making millions
of dollars here man and they figured it
out dude i got to hear the story what
happened this is incredible yeah how did
you do this uh so we bought a new house
and uh we kept our old one as a rental
because we just that's what people do i
guess and then about a year into it we
decided that was not really good for us
so i started researching whether we
should sell that house or not and that's
how i tripped on your materials um
and after that we decided to sell it we
put all that money down on the on our
current house the new house that we
bought i was messing around with excel
and you could see how much you would
save by putting that amount of money
forty thousand dollars down on it and it
was just incredible oh it blows your
mind yeah and so then i wish you got rid
of the hassle
right yes that was my life and mostly
him he took care of yeah it's not pain
in the butt yeah it is yeah it wasn't
for us um
so then i just deep dived into your
material dave uh i just kept going to
crin and saying okay you know let's put
you know a little extra money on the
house and we can get it paid off early
and i just say okay sounds good i come
back to ourselves okay i think we can do
a little bit more totally fine and then
a little bit more and it just kept going
like that
when did you finally say enough
i didn't
no i mean i was i was on board i i
really he incrementally warmed you up to
where you didn't even realize how crazy
you got it's like a frog
completely and he um i just trusted him
completely with the finances he kind of
handled it and i she's sweet well and i
just i mean he would talk to me about it
and when he showed me that excel
spreadsheet and said we're going to save
this much
that was powerful
then on that basis we're doing this
i like that as much as i trusted him
okay yes i looked at the numbers and
then i trusted him
well and then i think what really
happened is cove it happened and then
that's when i well he'd always listen to
you um actually one time i even asked
him in the car i said why do you listen
to him you know all the answers because
he would spout him out before you
and um it was fairly easy yes
covet hit and and news was just gloomy
and sad and everybody was depressing so
i thought i'm gonna i'm gonna listen to
dave ramsey and i got hooked you were
hopeful and you were upbeat and you you
and john deloney specifically just
helped in those very early months of
covid for me
and i started listening and thinking
this this is actually something i want
to do and you offered financial peace
for free and so we watched it at home
after the girls would go to bed
and
as i
i watched all your classes i realized oh
man our opportunities will increase if
we do this if we pay off the house
and then also your generosity video
really spoke to me i was like i want to
be that person that offers to pay for
somebody at the grocery store which i've
done once and he turned me down so
um
and then that's where we just
really started dialing it up i think
that going through that class really
clicked into the why and for me it was
like man what does this future look like
with the girls what kind of trips can we
do for them pay for their college maybe
buy them a home later in life and then
for corinne it was for the girls it was
for education i didn't really want to go
public schools and i wanted to have that
opportunity to either do homeschool or
private school and without having the
financial burden of a mortgage it just
allowed me to either go par you know
even more part-time or quit my job or
private and
just opportunities wow
way to go you guys you're amazing well
done so powerful the last 24 36 months
has been real tough on police officers
how have you kept your foot on the gas
at home while also navigating a really
just a tough work environment
uh great question i wasn't prepared for
that one um
yeah you know i i that goes to kind of
like how you do it and i think it's just
really intentionality for us was
we just had that goal and it sort of
drove what we chose to do and what we
chose not to do in our lives and i've
just found that you're successful at
what you're intentional at and so
we really dove into the the house
and i wouldn't say we made huge
sacrifices but it was just consistent
choices and then i think that's the same
at work too is you just have to make
consistent choices of
i'm here to do this i'm here to serve my
community i want to make a difference
and i just got to keep reminding myself
that because there is a whole lot of
people that will tell you that you're
there for a different reason yeah that's
incredible yeah
i i'm not you know i read the other day
a guy said i'm not responsible
for the narrative of me that you have in
your head that's right
but that idea if i tell you what
you just summed up therapy you summed up
workout programs diet programs
goals are a a function of what you're
intentional about period in business you
just summed it up right there that's
incredible guys
you're well done not even 40. so i'm not
getting i don't know how to wrap my head
around it yeah it's beautiful beautiful
how does it feel to not have a payment
in the world
uh it feels great i mean yeah
it's still a little weird i i have to
admit i had i haven't really felt it yet
but yeah i don't know it's kind of
surreal yeah it's very certain to not
even be 40 and i think both of us
secretly had a little
goal to do this before we were 40. so
not a secret anymore yeah it's not the
secret's out you did it
i can't wait till uh
kyle you're gonna pull somebody over in
about six months and they're gonna be
like oh millionaire giving me a ticket
that's what i'm talking about
that's gonna happen that's gonna happen
next week
oh my god
congratulations hard to be intimidating
now
that's always been hard for me
oh my goodness
well done you guys we got a copy of baby
steps millionaires for you you should be
in the book you did it exactly the way
that uh is laid out here five years they
pay off their mortgage from the time
they set the goal 750 000 are paid for
home
at um not even 40 years old also copy
total money makeover you can give that
away to somebody and continue to spread
the ruckus that we're causing out here
in america we're trying to stir it up
and we appreciate all you guys out there
helping us do
just that spread the word about the
podcast spread the word about the
debt-free screams spread the word about
dr john's number one best-selling book
spread the word about the number one
bestseller baby steps millionaires
because i'm sitting here looking at two
of them boom this stuff is real people
this stuff is real i'm so proud of y'all
it works yeah it really does
yeah we got a great story about the the
total money makeover corinne came to me
was like i'm not sure who who we're
going to give the book to right and i
was like don't worry god will tell us
who to give it to and the next day
she came to some with somebody that said
hey i want to talk to you about that
dave ramsey guy there it is just like
that all right let's bring the girls up
what are their names and ages
uh penny is six and hattie is three all
right we're gonna do our debt-free
scream house and everything those two
right there have had their lives changed
their family tree has changed by their
brave courageous mom and dad 273 000
paid off in five years making 92 to 140
house and everything
baby steps millionaires before their 40
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream three two one we're done
[Applause]
i love it
so cool man as rachel always says
there was a day i was that little girl
yep man it goes quick this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today exodus 15 13 in your
unfailing love you will lead the people
you have redeemed in your strength you
will guide them to your holy dwelling
joe dimaggio said a person always doing
his or her best becomes a natural leader
just
by
example dr john deloney ramsey
personality is my co-host today open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five shane is with us in
cleveland ohio hi shane welcome to the
ramsey show
hey thank you both it's an honor to be
speaking with you you too what's up
hey so my question is this i guess a
little context my wife and i discovered
your program two years ago uh which a
lot of happened in the last few years
obviously very thankful for that and we
are we'll be in baby step seven a year
from today is our plan and my question
to you is uh does it ever make sense to
have more than one financial advisor in
your corner
what would be the purpose
so we've been looking through the elps
we've been shopping around and we found
some really great people in our area and
they're just a few that we really like
and we're just curious if it makes sense
to maybe give a little bit of money one
and then a little bit of money to the
other and see who performs better is
that just over complicating things or
does it make sense to do that i i try to
keep things as simple as possible yeah
um
it's using the tool wrong
it's not up to them to perform it's up
to you to perform
it's up to them to teach you
and you make the decisions
and if both of them are teaching you and
they're giving you slightly different uh
teaching then you're just going to be
confused
so i would use one
but you don't want to you're not handing
them the money as a test and going okay
who wins the race
because they're not in the race you are
you see the difference
yeah that makes a lot of sense yeah and
so
um
you know i don't get two tax guys to run
my or tax people to run my uh tax
returns and see who wins
i need my taxes done right with the most
possible
uh money not going to the government the
least money going to the government
possible and um you know so that that's
the goal that is legal and moral and
you know uh we just came through an
audit which is the first time i've
gotten that wonderful um
inspection of my body parts
right yeah unbelievable and it came out
you know what i came out with
owing zero
wow that's how good we are because we're
fanatics about the integrity of doing it
properly right yeah we don't lie we
don't cut corners we don't cheat i hate
taxes
i hate that the government takes so much
of my money but i'm going to do it
exactly right so it's my job to make
sure that the stuff's filed right and i
use an an advisor a
a professional in that corner yeah i i
just learned to play golf i've been
learning to play golf i'm not any good
in the last three years
and one of the best pieces of advice i
got and everybody's got a freaking
opinion about golf i've never seen a
sport
with as much
diverse
stupid stuff in it i mean my god
and so but one of the the single best
piece of advice i got is don't get more
than one coach
because they'll just they'll make you
schizophrenic at your golf swing and you
know make you multiple personalities
with your golf swing whatever whatever
the phrase is it's a metaphor here but
um anyway so yeah i i so i got one guy
and i'm doing that one when i cease to
believe that he's moving me to the next
level then i'll get a different guy well
and that's what i heard here is
i like them i wanna i wanna prove i want
them to prove themselves to me and if
you don't trust the person yeah with
your retirement account that's teaching
you go to somebody else but the proving
needs to be did i learn something and am
i comfortable making these choices
because they showed me how to handle my
money right not because i handed it to
them and one of them does better than
the other or they gave me some magic
dust package that was going to exhibit
tax returns right the financial world is
full of those people yes yep that's
exactly right that that's what we're
looking for so that's a really good
question
but yeah i use one
[Music]
uh insurance professional i use one
real estate professional my son-in-law i
used one uh
you know i i won golf coach
uh one uh
smartvestor pro that makes sense because
i sent you an email back just asking if
i could help you with your golf swing
and you never wrote back
i now understand it wasn't because of me
it's because i have played golf with
happy gilmore
you know the running you know the
running swing that gilmore has as he
runs at the ball with a driver i'm not
great this is john i'm not great i play
with john and john drove a 310 yard
green
on the 18th green he drove the green 310
yards the rest of the day he drove the
woods
with style hey man i mean i'm not great
i don't know how many balls he started
with i know how many he ended with
hey i borrowed some of these clubs
because i don't have my own and uh a
week later they like hey man you owe me
like 20 bucks yeah you torp my club
balls
no that was 200 bucks
20 bucks wouldn't bought those golf
balls i'm not great dave i'm not great
not great yeah that's well you brought
it up i you brought up coaching me so
i'm just saying
uh i'm not great but i'm
not happy gilmore you're better than me
uh i was afraid we're gonna have to go
into that in the pond out with that
alligator and get some others back
oh thank you thank you adam sandler for
the memories
uh all right open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five
timothy's in washington dc hi timothy
how are you
hi dave thank you so much for taking my
call sure how can we help
so i have just started a brand new job
coincidentally in the federal government
working for the library of congress in
their braille music division
and
i am very illiterate when it comes to
benefits and retirement and stuff i've
heard my parents talk about it but i
never actually pursued it very deeply to
learn all the ins and outs of what each
thing means
i've been in touch a little bit with
your smartvestor pros and um
they told me i should need to get a
financial cushion under my belt first
before i think about investing
and um so i just wanted to find out from
you what your advice would be to someone
who's 28 years old just starting at work
and
basically starting from the bare bones
bottom i have no debt
at all yeah you're ahead you're way
ahead brother congratulations actually
people don't start from the bottom they
usually start from subterranean and they
have to get dig up to the bottom but
yeah you are starting the bottom but hey
congratulations so braille
music is that what you said
yes sir that's so cool are you braille
literate
i'm assuming so
very cool man
are you sight impaired blind i'm sorry
yes i am i'm totally blind okay wow good
for you man that's a great job rockstar
dude that is so cool
all right so the the process will not be
any different and so what you're saying
is is that i don't even have the basic
uh tool set i need a starter tool set to
get going with this whole money thing
agreed well i've got financial peace i
do i'm in the ramsey plus membership
okay so
yeah obviously the uh audio
of all of that is very valuable to you
then
oh yes and then i do have access to some
of your books electronically there's a
website called bookshare that has a lot
of your material yep yep we tried to
make sure they get it so that's good and
we appreciate them carrying it so the uh
good good okay so that's it i mean
you're gonna work the baby steps you're
gonna make sure you have the proper uh
insurances in place and that's one of
your lessons in financial peace
university you're going to uh you know
make sure you get your emergency fund in
place which is what your smart investor
pro told you to do and then you're going
to start investing and
you said it's a federal employee federal
government employee right
yes sir okay so you got the tsp
available to you
and when you start doing that you're
going to investigate you're probably
going to want to do about 80 percent in
the c
about 10 in the s and about 10 in the i
uh that's small company and
international the sea is common stock
it's about like an s p 500 fund and if
you put money in those for uh
a couple decades you'll probably be a
millionaire
if you load them up that's awesome and
so you'll be on your way and uh you're
right on track you're a neat guy man
that's so cool i'm glad to hear that i
didn't even know that existed that the
braille music
that's so cool the library congress is
i know it's fascinating
but i mean that's amazing very cool good
show john and james and ben and
everybody in the booth everybody thank
you thank you thank you that puts this
hour of the day bringing up the ramsay
show in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
jesus
hey it's john deloney co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com